He's been a musclebound military man with
biceps with size of Christmas hams.
He's served time in the Vietnam War and seen
things most could never imagine.
He was even a snake-seller in Thailand for
a while.
But now, John Rambo is a cowboy, baby.
To celebrate the start of filming on Rambo
5, the upcoming installment in the action-packed
Rambo franchise, series star Sylvester Stallone
shared two images of himself in character
as Rambo.
One might have expected to see the iconic
action hero standing shirtless in a jungle,
wielding a massive weapon, sweating profusely,
and scowling at the camera in Rambo 5 – because,
you know, he's Rambo and that's who Rambo
is.
Or at least that's who he was.
In the first snap Stallone shared on his Instagram
account, his new cowboy-Rambo looks off camera
as he slips on a suede work glove.
In the caption, he wrote,
"Tonight we start filming…!"
While the first photo appears to have been
taken during a costume and makeup test shoot,
the second image was definitely taken on set.
Stallone is mounted on a dun-colored horse,
his head tilted down toward the forest floor.
Stallone captioned that snap, "Comes a Horseman
Wild and Free," a reference to Canadian singer-songwriter
Gordon Lightfoot's 1972 track "Don Quixote."
Confusing as the first-look photos may be,
there's actually a solid reason why Rambo
will look more like John Wayne in the new
Rambo.
The film will begin with Rambo living on his
father's ranch in Arizona the same one he
returned to at the end of Rambo 4.
According to Screen Daily, Rambo will go about
his everyday farm duties until he learns that
he must hunt down one of Mexico's deadliest,
most ruthless cartels who have kidnapped his
friend's daughter.
While some have found cowboy-hat-wearing Rambo
a bit strange, fans should thank their lucky
stars that they're even seeing snaps of Stallone
filming Rambo 5 in the first place, since
the actor was just a few years ago prepared
to say goodbye to Rambo for good.
In May 2010, Stallone told Empire that he
was, quote, "done [with Rambo]" and that he
was "99 percent sure" a fifth Rambo movie
wasn't going to happen.
"I think Rambo's pretty well done.
I don't think there'll be any more.
[…] I feel that with Rocky Balboa, that
character came complete circle.
He went home.
But for Rambo to go on another adventure might
be, I think, misinterpreted as a mercenary
gesture and not necessary."
At the time, he added that he was happy with
Rambo 4 and where his character's story ended,
due in large part to the fact that, as Stallone
put it, he "didn't pull any punches" while
writing the film's script or in directing
the movie.
He explained,
"I wanted it to be what civil war really is:
rough.
You can't candy coat it.
And where do you go from there?"
Stallone apparently had a change of heart
shortly thereafter.
In July 2010, he opened up during a fan Q&A
session held on Ain't It Cool about what the
future held for the Rambo franchise.
Asked whether he would want to further explore
Rambo's back story, Stallone admitted that
he thought the possibility of a Rambo prequel
was "worth pondering," and that it would be
interesting for him to direct a new actor
as a younger Rambo.
He explained,
"The traumas, the loss and the tragedy of
being in Vietnam would certainly be a great
challenge for a young actor, and it would
be ironic that Rambo directs younger Rambo
having played it for 20 years plus."
Obviously, all that thought turned into action,
and Stallone eventually agreed to starring
in a fifth Rambo movie.
Though he's traded in his signature bandana
and mullet for some new headgear, Rambo is
coming back in full force with a fresh aesthetic
to boot for Rambo 5, due out sometime in fall
2019.